you recently performed in your hometown
so like when you do a show because
you've had so many pits there's so many
things people want to hear you saying
but is there one that you'd still love
doing like is there a favorite song of
yours uh well in reference to to Memphis
playing the show there it that was the
first time we played uh
selfish um so that made you were there
oh my
gosh wow I still the bracelet on oh my
gosh look yeah I I when I found out you
were performing I lit Lally booked a
flight booked hotels not knowing I was
getting in and that's why we have C and
I
literally I live in Jersy did you have
did you have a good time I amazing time
I still have the bracelet on I can't
take myself to and I found out I was
coming here yest did you know he was
going to drop the new single yes I mean
all the subliminal messaging on your you
know your Tik Tok we you know we try to
figure it out EG I like it I like it
we're like CIA agents but yes I it was
was unbelievable and I can't wait to
well as we say in Memphis thanks for
coming thanks for coming unbelievable
I'll do it come on back anytime you
won't well so you did the new song There
selfish but what's like one of your
favorite like like I always still love
doing Miss Independent yeah like I I
always love doing Miss Independent it's
my first single and I don't know why I
love it live I love it live what is do
you have a favorite I mean rock your
body's fun Still
Rock mirrors mirrors is still fun to
sing although sometimes I'm like why did
I write this in this key it's very high
that's what I say a lot um yeah yeah cuz
that's why I don't go on stage until
like 900
p.m. yes you're isn't there yet it's not
there yet not there yet what do you this
is a real question great impersonation
by the
way I was trying to do my falsetto and I
my head voice and I was like don't suck
um I enjoyed
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home